and i remember when i was in in 2008 i
was in rehab and uh you came to to visit
me just to show love and support it
meant so much
there was one uh
visit where you showed up and and you
had like the full like your hair had
grown out i was like whoa knoxville's
got gray hair
and that was that was 2008. yeah i let
it go gray for a little while i just got
sick of it
and but madison told me that she liked
it dark and so i started coloring my
hair my daughter madison told me she
liked the dark so i started coloring my
hair again
i remember saying so when did uh
when did you start when did you first
color your hair
in my late 20s that's crazy man yeah i
was going gray
soon my dad was completely white-haired
at 19. wow yeah
steve martin yeah
wow that that that's crazy man and um
i mean it have you handled the this all
this
what do you call it the reveal like uh
i think you had a fun way of describing
all of a sudden uh revealing the gray
hair silver foxville oh yeah
no i yeah i can't remember what i said
but there's something about
uh i can't remember i remember writing
you something about
right
and it just seems with full confidence
like for every i think that uh from i'm
i'm so much more of a sensitive like uh
you don't like going gray i enjoy it
yeah steve doesn't like aging at all
yeah
i'm done aging yeah well you're in that
uh i think everyone gets a little bummed
on aging but you're in that place where
it's just a little gray right so you're
just coming to terms with it i had many
years to come to terms with it i knew
what was under here
you know yeah yeah so
so was that like a very freeing like
acceptance of
growing old or just even
like we've never been great on camera
before have you
yeah was that hard to do
no i was so i did feel liberated because
like i have to go every three weeks
to get my hair colored and after a
couple of weeks it would start you'd see
the white everywhere and it's just a
drag
right so it's like a lot of work it's a
lot of work
yeah and um
who thought we'd be talking about hair
coloring on this
but it's true but i'm psyched i'm so
happy with
that i don't have to color it anymore
and i like look look what that looks
like what that oh a lot of
i've only seen really uh
positive feedback about it yeah i think
it's great
yeah dude